one of the biggest use cases of ETFs is
by other fund managers and institutions
so I mentioned advisers like they're the
biggest target market for these ETFs
right though that they take up 2third
maybe 70% or more of the Assets in the
ETF world in the US that's the target
market here for most people but also
institutions make up a huge chunk of
this they were these things were built
for institutions to be trading vehicles
and right now for the most part many
institutions can't hold this thing like
they're literally restricted from doing
it because of the way that they were
structured and built and this rapper
will allow them to get exposure to this
asset class within the bounds of of how
they were
created all right guys bang bang I've
got James here Eric may be joining us
maybe not we're gonna see he's on train
right now but uh James um ETFs are
approved Bitcoin spot ETFs you guys had
90 plus percent uh confidence you were
right congratulations I think every
people on the internet are joking this
is your Super Bowl um how do you look at
so many different TFS getting approved
at the same time like is that something
that we've seen a lot in the past or is
it usually like one or two and then some
trickle in over time yeah I mean this is
a oneofone situation I mean the the
closest situation is what we just saw
with ethereum Futures ETFs in October um
they got no interest whatsoever for the
most part uh a lot of the same people
were in that race and and no one really
bought those they took they took no no
one that no one wanted to bite them I
think part of the reason for that is
because I also think spot ethereum ETFs
are going to be approved this year um
which we can get into a little later uh
but yeah this is a oneof one situation
like there there's been so much hype and
uh so many applications this has been
going on for 10 years I mean really the
wink ofal twins applied over 10 years
ago but for the most part it's really
heated up over the last four to five
years 2017 is um so I guess that's even
more um but things have really heated up
a lot here and the SEC has decided they
don't want to be a kingmaker in the way
they were with PR shar's BTO the Bitcoin
Futures ETF which commands 95% of the
assets 95 plus per of the trading volume
in Bitcoin Futures ETFs and US exchanges
so um they don't want to be kingmaker
and so they're doing everything they can
to line everyone up which is also
something we've been saying since since
even long before we went to 90% odds in
October yeah I definitely think this is
the fair way to do it the first time I
said it on television uh one of the host
was like wait you think they would do
that and I was like it's the only fair
way they they should do it that way uh
doing it any other way seems kind of
unfair but what is your expectation of
asset inflows let's go maybe like 48
hours and then 30 days so in the first
two days what do you expect and then in
the first 30 days what do you
expect yeah so we've heard so initially
so if you had asked me this before the
ethereum Futures launch I would have
said it was going to break they were
they naturally all of them would break
the ETF records um that currently Bido
holds it was the fastest to a billion it
basically did it in two days um I think
this then the ethereum Futures launch
happened and just the interest was
waning in this space I thought but I
guess I was wrong we've heard rumors
like corroborated rumors from multiable
people that many of these issuers have
hundreds of millions of cap Capital
lined up to invest in day one or day two
there's rumors that black rock has 2
billion lined up potentially um which is
an insane number in my mind I I I'll
believe it when I see it I guess so I
mean these we're talking about serious
Capital here that would be flowing into
the space um so time will tell so you
said 48 hours I mean the problem is if
gray scale goes first it's going to be
you're going to have to do net flows
because I think there will be
significant Capital if gray scale goes
in the same day that will flow out of
gbtc and into these other products gbt
fee they're only Dr to 1.5% as of this
recording right so um that's a
relatively High fee and I could see them
basically a lot of people who maybe own
them in tax deferred accounts or who
don't really care are going to take
their money out there's also a lot of
hedge funds and private Equity Funds and
people that are owning that thing that
don't want exposure to bitcoin they're
only viewing it as a special situation
because it's trading at such a steep
discount or was trading at such a steep
discount so maybe they just get out of
it once the Discount closes and this
thing becomes an ETF um so if you net it
out I don't it's hard to predict these
types of things but I think it will be
measured in in in billions for sure if
we're talking at the end of the first
week I think we'll see net flows of I
don't know three to four three billion
potentially I mean over the year I'm on
record to saying I was thinking around
10 billion as the over-under so I'd
probably go over 10 if for the first
year but under 25 I've seen some crazy
numbers for the first year um I guess
we'll see um but net flows wise I'm I'm
probably around that over 10 but not
much over 10 if I had to guess for the
first year
all right first 48 hours I'm definitely
over two billion like I think this thing
is going to smash every record you guys
are going to like build a monument
inside ETF land of like what's gonna
happen um but I I don't think it's uh
yeah over 10 under 25 like that seems
pretty reasonable I saw the 50 to 100
billion number that came out uh that
seems tough but I don't know maybe
bitcoin's price if it triples plus
inflows like maybe that helps it yeah if
you get to AUM levels there I don't
think that would be absolutely insane
particularly if the price appreciates
the levels that we've already seen in
the past back in 2021 um that said if
you look at gold ETFs which is like a
the most analogous situation to in in
ETF history I guess you would say they
have 100 billion assets I've said this
on like a whole bunch of different
podcasts and spaces and what have you
and I just don't I mean it's possible
I'm completely wrong but I think of that
as like the upper end I think I think
these ETFs could get to like one 2% of
total fund total ETF AUM right now we're
at 8 trillion so if you take 1 to 2%
over the long term say four or five
years from now that would say assuming
the assets don't change but you're
talking what 80 billion plus to 100 plus
but I don't that that's much longer term
um I I don't think we're going to see
those numbers short term black rock is
uh I'm sorry uh great scale is coming in
at 1.5 they were at 2% they're dropping
at 1.5 uh everyone else is like sub one
right and many of them are kind of like
0.25 to 0
fiveish um how much of a difference is
there between 0.25 and like there's
obviously a big difference between 150
basis points and 50 but what about the
like big bunched up group between 25
basis points and 50 basis points does it
matter it's honestly going to be
fascinating to see I mean the way I
think about it is right there's going to
be a whole bunch of different ways that
everyone's going to try to spin these
you have the the more crypto native
people and the people that are more in
crypto I'll lump vanck and Arc into that
because Arc is partnered with 21 shares
man has been trying to get these things
through the door has been at crypto
conferences that I've ever been to
they've always there um and then you
have bitwise which has been basically
pounding the table pounding the ground
on this front same with Valkyrie hash
decks so like there's this echo of like
we're focused on this ecosystem a lot
and some are like we're only focused on
this ecosystem like 21 shares and some
of those other names I just mentioned um
but then you also have the big players
like I shares and Fidelity which
obviously Fidelity has been in the space
for a long time so they're going to
differentiate on brand name and say like
what they're trying to do here um the
fees though I think are critical I think
if you have a relationship with one of
these issuers or that are trying to sell
these things as long as you're
competitive you're not like I think 50
might honestly even be too high so right
now Invesco and Galaxy they're offering
a six-month waiver so there'll be no fee
for the first six months and up to five
billion potentially um but then they're
going to 59 bips I think they might have
to lower that to be competitive
potentially but I guess time will tell
um but if you're in like the 39 bip
range like Fidelity is but you have a
relationship with Fidelity and you're
thinking about going to somebody like um
I don't know bitwise or ey shares like
might not be enough if you already have
a relationship so as long as they're
competitive the distri distribution
networks will be important because the
way we're looking at this is it this
whole ETFs tend to be a win or TI most
situation right one fund tends to get
most of the assets and most if not most
of the liquidity um definitively
liquidity um but that means that there's
a huge opening for plenty of other
people to have Niche markets where they
have a 100 million maybe a little bit
more in assets that is profitable enough
or at least somewhat profitable that
they can offer the business and it's
just something that they want to have to
complete what the complete their
offering when they go to an advisor's
office or an institution's office but
there's going to be one or two that sit
at the top on that asset level or uh
trading level and in in some cases in
very mature markets we actually see one
that is basically competing on assets um
because it has such a low fee level but
the dollar volume when things go crazy
it's always one and it's usually the
oldest one that tends to really dominate
on liquidity and volume and we see that
repeatedly in different areas of the ETF
ecosystem after 30 days who emerges with
the most Assets in your opinion this
episode is brought to you by frck
historically the wealthy had a hidden
secret in investing they would spend a
lot of money and use very big teams to
conduct tax loss harvesting tax loss
harvesting is the timely selling of
Securities at a loss to offset the
amount of capital gains tax owed from
selling the profitable assets later but
now frck is bringing this incredible
advantage to any investor they'll
literally lower your tax bill regardless
of how much money you have they use stay
of theart Technology through a product
called direct indexing to allow
investors to invest in the S&P 500 while
getting all the benefits of tax loss
harvesting without the big Bill if you
want to learn more go check them out at
fre.com that's
fc.com I'm a big fan of the product and
I even became an investor in the
business frk.com go check them out today
I mean even with grale going at 1.5% I
think it's I mean they would have to see
it record-breaking levels of outflows in
a short time period to unseat them on an
asset basis but that said if anyone can
do it it's probably ey shares just
because of black Rock's brand name um
they're also their fee waiver isn't
bringing it to to 0% but it is bringing
it down to 20 basis points which is also
extremely low look I I've been telling
people to expect the terod doome we we
call the ETF terod doome it's because
it's it just it crushes you it forces
people to cut fees if you want to
compete and we were talking about 40
basis points as like a lowend getting
under 40 would be impressive we think it
could happen within a year and then
Fidelity did out the out of the gate and
we were like oh wow they're already
doing it and then now with these recent
updates I I'm absolutely shocked uh how
low these have gone we they basically
compressed a year or so of of fee War um
down into a 36 48 hour period and and
honestly we're still we might still not
be done that technically speaking they
could lower the fees again if some of
these issuers really wanted to the idea
of waving the fees for six months or up
to a billion dollars or or whatever it
is um why not go even longer like is it
just hey the difference between 6 months
and 12 months doesn't really matter it's
more so just the the gesture of waving
the fee at all or how should people
think about uh what these cies are going
through yeah the way I'm thinking about
it is one we've never had a situation
like this so in the time and sometimes
you have issuers come late to a party
and they'll do that V waver to try and
gather new any new assets looking for a
specific strategy or asset class in this
case I mean everyone's just trying to do
something to differentiate themselves
right the way I'm thinking about it is
it's almost like a marketing expense
like here you go we're going to eat the
cost of operating this thing which I
think many of these even at the fees
they're currently offered unless they
get significant assets they're probably
going to be operating like at a loss or
like with virtually no profit uh to
start um so this is not like this is not
like this is going to be a cash cow for
these guys in the near term like this is
they're coming out and they're going
with razor thin margins probably we
there's a reason everyone on the very
low end is on that 20ish 20 to 30 Mark
right like there's there's a reason
they're that low and it's probably
because that's just how low things can
get compressed right now with the EOS
system but over time as as more scale
comes into the space we'll we'll
actually see this probably drop even
lower um but it's it's will be
interesting to see how much scale comes
in and how much it impacts the the
underlying fees but there's nothing to
say that like black rock if they get
enough assets it's possible that they
just get rid of it and change their
actual fee to 20 bips rather than going
to what they're stating at 30 bips but
anyone can really do that too um um and
and again we right now all these
documents they're we call them red
herring documents it's a common term it
has all this red writing that basically
says these are subject to completion and
all of these documents have that so we
could still see some of the stuff change
um before these things begin trading so
another thing that I saw was Vanek is
going to donate 5% of their Bitcoin spot
ETF to bitcoin developers uh I had
written a tweet a couple of days before
they announced that and that was one of
my suggestions and then I talked to
someone there and they're like no dude
we did this with the ethereum uh uh ETF
just no one really paid attention to it
and so they're like we were laughing
when we saw the Tweet because like that
was the plan already so one Why did no
one pay attention like does it not
matter and then two do you think it'll
help here with the Bitcoin spot ETF I
mean I talked about it I was covering it
when they they did it with the ethereum
ETF right so um but yeah nobody nobody
seems to care I guess for whatever
reason um it's it's interesting and it
shows they like their not just some like
tourist in this space that's one way
that they can show it um and they have
people the thing is like everybody has
hired people at this point that have
good pedigree and background in some
cases on both sides of the trafi and
defi World um so it's not like these
guys are just going in and don't have
any they have no idea how this Market
works these are all uh they're they're
they're very smart people and they have
good good uh good contact so I mean
vanak is doing it and hoping that maybe
the crypto native players who want
exposure to this in something like maybe
they have an IRA or some sort of account
so they're trying to go after people who
really care about that industry whereas
some of these other guys so their ticker
is H odl that's obviously a little more
retail and crypto specific you have
Valkyrie where whose ticker is brr R for
Burr like money printer um and then
other guys they they're going with much
more simple tickers which is indicative
of them like going more after the Boomer
advisor type crowd they're not going for
this flashy ticker um so you're going to
see these people both they're going to
compete but they're going to try to
compete potentially in different
channels maybe um so it's going to be
fascinating to see we've never seen this
many ETFs launch something and where the
products will be so similar um it'll
it's really I mean I'm a nerd but it'll
be interesting to watch and see how this
plays out so the fee War I think we all
knew it was coming to your point uh it
came much faster and much more severe
than than I think most were anticipating
um I'm probably more interested in the
marketing war that is going to happen
after this so I think that probably $100
million get spent at least throughout
the first year on marketing these things
it's probably a Super Bowl ad like
there's a bunch of these Milestones you
can kind of think through am I off base
there like how should we think about
what to expect are we just gonna like
literally every time we turn on CNBC
Bloomberg uh or any of these platforms
like just get bombarded with ETF Bitcoin
ads now or or what should we expect so
it's funny technically they're not
legally allowed to put like the ETF
ticker or anything in any of those
marketing so if you looked at any of
them like none of them specifically have
like like an ETF ticker in there they
just talk about in this case Bitcoin and
then provide a like show their like uh
their company name and and a link to
their website so I do think there is we
know for a fact we've been saying I mean
I think Eric wrote in October that this
was going to be a marketing blood bath
it's going to be people are going to be
going neck and neck here they're going
to do anything they can to try and
differentiate themselves and they're
going to try to Market these products
and so like some of these smaller issues
going against these massive firms with
significant marketing Capital um it will
be interesting to see but we've already
SE some of the smaller guys come out
with with really in my opinion smart
funny
commercials and when you see that
happening in other ETFs is there a
connection between you spend more you
you gather more in
assets not really it's not that big of a
deal the marketing spend on like
commercials and stuff like you're
talking about here right the only ones
that we see it for are things like the
cues and some of the spider products
like you've seen on Center ice at at the
at the Rangers games and things like
that but those are are different because
those those ETFs are structured a way
that no ETFs are structured anymore um
they're structured as unit trusts unit
investment trusts and they have 12 V1
fees which are basically part of your
expense ratio goes to spending money on
marketing it's like Brewster's Millions
Like These funds have like billions and
billions of dollars and they have like 0
one% that goes to marketing but it ends
up being millions and millions of
dollars that they have to spend on
marketing um so they kind of use that to
create commercials and different things
like that but this is more unique you
don't see too many things like this uh
as much as I'm kind of expecting this is
going to be again a sort of oneofone
situation as far as as ETF advertising
goes so one of the other things that I
see people talking about I think Gabor
gabox who used to be at Vanek is now an
adviser there um he was like look all
these low fees like it's great for the
people who are going to be investing it
obviously everyone wants the lowest fee
possible but it may actually incentivize
other behavior for these issuers to try
to make money including trading uh
Securities lending Etc on the back end
how much of that are should people be
worried about or should they be aware of
yeah I mean one they can't do any
Securities lending without disclosing in
their documents right so that concern I
saw from multiple people online that
just don't understand the ETF World
specifically so if they're going to be
doing that and they do it and don't
disclose in their documents I mean
they're going to it's that's nightmare
situation for them they're going to
disclose it plenty of ETFs do it um I
don't even I'm actually don't think that
the granter trust structure that all of
these are using in the 33 act I don't
think they're even allowed to do
Securities lending if they wanted to so
I think ultimately people will figure
out wrappers and ways to offer this type
of exposure and do some sort of
Securities lending or in the case of of
eth do some sort of staking um down the
line but not initially this is they
can't do that what I think what people
are realizing with these fees is like
these are kind of like like I said
they're offering them at cost or
possibly even loss leaders um and then
we'll see where things go and hope they
get the scale where they're actually
profitable but like I I don't know I I
don't think the incentivizing bad
behavior is necessarily true I mean it's
possible um but in the US market
specifically with the way the granter
trust is set up with these names like
Black Rock isn't going to be playing
fast and loose with the names that said
as far as trading goes the one
interesting thing that everyone was
focused on a few weeks back was whether
or not these ETFs will be able to
operate with in kind or cash create
redeem so most ETFs for the most part if
you it's with S&P 500 you hand over all
the stocks in the S&P 500 and you get
back shares at the ETF for Bitcoin it
would be handing over Bitcoin and
getting back shares of the ETF that
represent ownership of that Bitcoin the
SEC basically said no go you cannot do
incine create rede create and Redemption
um so here we are you're only allow to
do cash and a lot of people tried to
fight it including grayscale Black Rock
you name it they wanted to do in Kind
part of the reason they wanted to do
that is because when you do in kind all
the trading and acquiring of the asset
is done by the market makers and the
authorized participants think Jane
Street verto JP Morgan um these PE these
big Wall Street Banks and broker broker
dealers what have you GTS throwing a
names are probably people don't really
know but this is like the people who do
all the trading on Wall Street and they
are the best at trading there's a reason
why they make millions of dollars
because they are very efficient with
technology and how fast they are at
trading these things but by making it
cash create those market makers and
those authorized participants they can't
hand over Bitcoin because yes we can get
into why they're doing it but
essentially they're handing over cash to
the issuers and the issuers have to then
go out and buy the Bitcoin or in vice
versa if there is a Redemption they're
selling the Bitcoin and handing over
cash there is so that means that all of
the trading and the relationships for
getting the execution of the underlying
Bitcoin for the fund is going to be
within the issue which most of these
issuers are not used to doing um so it's
probably going to be outsourced to
different people I don't know exactly
how it's going to work I need to dive
into that a little bit more but for the
most part it's going to be interesting
to see so you could end up with a case
where one of these ETFs has a situation
where they don't have the best execution
of getting exposure to the Bitcoin and
their performance is going to lag
another one who has the best traders in
the market now I don't know how long it
would take for something like that to
show up but that is one area that could
happen here I but that said again I I
don't know how much bad behavior this is
going to incentivize um but I guess time
will tell and I hope I'm not proving
wrong I hope I hope Gabor is wrong and
everyone should hope that Gabor is wrong
here but Gabor knows his stuff and I've
known Gabor for basically since I got
out of college uh when he was working at
Vanek and before Bitcoin ETFs are even
really that big of a topic yeah
absolutely now um there's a ton of
benefits everyone's talking about the
positives uh Wall Street is now
embracing Bitcoin Etc uh there's
definitely GNA be some sort of trade-off
there's going to be some downside what
are some of the downsides that you would
expect for Bitcoin or Bitcoin holders
now that wall Street's involved this
episode is brought to you by cal.com
what do I have in common with Chad
Hurley from YouTube Toby from Shopify
and Alexis from 776 and the co-founder
of Reddit we all use cal.com
instead of cly and we are all early
investors as well cal.com is leading the
charge of scheduling Platforms in the
open source sphere offering you the
chance to harness the efficiency
previously reserved for elite
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all of the
benefits of open-source technology then
cal.com for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your time downsides I mean
I I personally I know this is probably
going to be out of consensus I don't
think there's that many downsides I mean
it's not going to be impacting the
underlying um structure of Bitcoin is
not changing the technology it's not
forcing anyone that they wants to hold
their own Bitcoin in cold storage or
take care of their own Keys obviously
not your keys not your coins um but for
the vast majority of people out there
particularly anyone in the advisor space
like they don't want to deal with that
particularly for something that most
people are going to put as two three 5%
of the portfolio right um so I think
just there it's almost all net positives
um as far as I'm concerned I I honestly
can't think of too many negatives
because you really it's not forcing
anyone to do anything and honestly you
talked about all the marketing aspect
the lower driving down to fees honestly
we didn't even talk about how these fees
that are driving down stuff driving down
these costs it's going to impact
everything else in the crypto ecosystem
look at some of these institutional uh
cust custodian fees they're higher than
the all-in expense ratios in some of
these fees if you want to use some of
these Bitcoin
custodians if I'm if I'm an
Institutional Investor and I'm custody
my Bitcoin with somebody else I already
have counterparty risk and the fee is 40
bips or what have you to custody my
Bitcoin there and I can go over to Black
Rock right now and get 20 bips or go
over to Arc or bitwise or or vanc you
name it Invesco at 0% for a little
while like everyone's going to have to
cut their fees the commissions are way
too high on some of these platforms when
you look at the compared to the trafi
market so I just think the the
reverberations are going to be positive
um I think it's more like that some of
those other platforms that you use are
going to have a hard time um with some
of those negative consequences that we
talk we spoke about because they're not
as regulated as these ETFs and these ETF
issuers are going to be part of the
reason why the the SEC
wants the Bitcoin ETF issuers to be the
ones that are doing the buying and
selling of Bitcoins because we're kyc
AML they they we already know you've
covered it that they don't want broker
dealers touching Bitcoin Sab 121 like
all these different things and basically
the issuers under the sec's purview the
SEC can dive in and look at exactly what
these issuers are doing at any point um
so I just don't think there's going to
be that many negative side effects I
don't know what negative side effects
are you worried about and I I'll give
you my my view on it dampening
volatility it will dampen Vol I I am
very I very strongly of the opinion that
these are going to dampen volatility
particularly if they get the significant
assets because I'm assuming you're
saying because these advisers what they
do just like many of the best Traders
when these things ride up they have set
allocation goals maybe if it's 5% of the
portfol
if this thing runs up 100% and becomes
10 15% of a client's portfolio they're
going to sell it and vice versa if this
thing Falls 80% they're going to buy it
and get it back to the set allocation
percentage and so basically that means
they're selling when things are ripping
and then they're going to be buying when
things are falling and that's going to
decrease the all on bitcoin and I think
that uh it's as it may be as simple as
uh before and after ETF like bitcoin's
life before and after ETF approval um
and you're going to have before ETF
approval asymmetric life and now you're
G to move more towards like a
traditional uh traditional asset yeah
I've I've I've always kind of viewed
this as um uh a call option on a store
value Asset is the way that I've always
kind of referred to it when I talk to
people um and this feels like or the the
it's not as much of a asymmetric anymore
once this happens maybe I guess is the
way that I would think about it so I
agree 100% with you on that all right
and I only and maybe I'm a weirdo and I
think that's a negative because you know
everyone wants the symmetric asset but
yeah if that's the worst thing that
comes out of this then I guess uh it's
pretty net positive right yeah I'm with
you 100% all right last two questions uh
th this is uh this is your guy Super
Bowl like I think everyone on the
internet just is so thankful what's been
the most fun part for you Andor Eric in
terms of uh let's call the last two
years or three years where it's really
kind of intensified you guys are putting
out you know uh confidence percentages
everyone on the Internet is like what do
these two guys think about the ETF
what's been the most fun part proving
people wrong that have just been ripping
on us for for months that has been the
best like just absolutely watching these
people cope uh with being wrong and so
like they they're literally just
constantly moving the goalpost on on
being wrong on these facts they've gone
from it's never going to happen to it
probably won't happen to even if it does
happen it's not going to matter it's not
going to get any assets nobody cares um
so yeah that's that's been the most
entertaining I guess I guess people
realizing that like we are covering this
from like a trafi perspective um and I
don't know we're we're just trying to
have fun with that be real people and
meeting I've met a lot of like really
cool really smart people in the space
because of it so uh yeah but definitely
the most fun for me has been because you
have people just constantly coming at
you saying why you're wrong you you deal
with it as much as if not more than
anyone with the amount of following you
have so um being Vindicated I guess is
definitely the most fun assuming it's
it's officially done it's all right look
the haters are the president of your fan
club just let let them keep keep
chirping that's fine um all right and
then once the ETFs uh are out there
assets are flown in what are you going
to do next like is will you ever Top
This is there another potential ETF that
could come along that could ever have
more scrutiny and excitement and you
know be talked on television every
single day about yeah this is the peak I
mean this is it this is this is it this
is the top um that said I mean we're
going to be covering this from trying to
figure out where things are going to go
next right like who's getting the assets
where's the volume going who's who's
trying to differentiate themselves who's
showing those addresses is doing proof
of Reserve who isn't uh so there's a lot
of things that people are still going to
be trying to figure out understanding
the nuances between all these different
products and then obviously I kind of
hinted at the beginning we think that
we're going to see spot e approvals so
that's the next thing I'm watching but I
don't think we get it's it's basically
Bitcoin and then maybe ethereum this
year and then I don't think anything
else happens like barring a literal like
people make jokes like you need an act
of Congress like you might literally
need an act of Congress or a complete
change in the admin uh through the the
2024 election um before we could get
another thing other than ethereum so I
think it's Bitcoin and ethereum and then
everything else so I mean I'll be
covering all of it as if there's more
assets that are going to come into this
rapper and we'll see how far down the
line we get maybe we have like bunch of
different of these digital Assets in the
ETF rapper in 10 years from now and I'll
be covering it there but yeah this is
this is the peak and just happy to have
been right so
far awesome where can we send people to
find you on the internet yeah I mean
obviously if you have a bloomer terminal
we we're writing on there we have a
dashboard on BF um Bel chunis uh who
couldn't join because he was his train
was too loud he didn't want to ruin the
the recording um he has a we have a show
ETF IQ on every Monday we have uh
trillions podcast and then also
obviously just my most active on on
Twitter JS FF um so you can follow me
there awesome well listen thank you so
much for doing this it's been a pleasure
to uh to watch you guys rise be right
and yeah you were one of the first ones
in this space to have us on so I I
haven't forgotten that you were one one
of the very few yeah nice yeah you know
what I actually I think I remember being
like Oh wait a second like these guys
are not like wacko yahoos who are just
like you know everything's going up they
like seem like they're like intelligent
about ETF and then I remember when I
talked to both of you um I remember
walking away being like oh this is like
that like that's one of the intersection
points right where obviously this like
new world and this old world are going
to meet and you guys are all over it so
you guys have done a fantastic job yeah
it's funny I tend to be like uh the much
more Pro side of this asset class and
Eric's more neutral to maybe even
positively slight negative but he's he's
mostly neutral and I find that most
people have been on the other side of
our calls here are just like they can't
separate the um prospects and what's
going on at the SEC with the underlying
asset class that they kind of hate um
but yeah it's been an interesting EOS
intersection here because I'm constantly
talking to trafi people trying to
explain like why this actually does
matter and then at the same time I go to
these crypto defi Bitcoin events and
like people are hyping things up and I
have to tone things down I'm like no it
it doesn't matter that much uh so I'm
like I'm like playing both sides
depending on who I'm talking to here I
lied I actually have one more question
um other funds taking their AUM and
putting it into the Bitcoin spot ETF we
saw one or two funds change their
perspectives and say they could put up
to 15% of the a is that going to be like
a trend that you think will get big and
actually lead to a lot of
inflows I don't think it's going to be
as big of an impact as some people have
made it out to be so I have basically on
my terminal I have all these alerts set
up that I look for certain documents
that change and add the words Bitcoin to
them essentially or have the words
Bitcoin in them and I have seen like
five or six different mutual funds
typically more liquid alt or alternative
or hedge fund type mutual funds that are
really active or hold Alternatives and
do alternative strategies and they're
just they're just adding the ability to
hold these things if indeed they want to
so like basically they have to put it in
their documents they can't just buy this
thing if they didn't put it in their
documents if they have the ability to do
it so so if it drops 80% and they want
to add a sliver to it like they need to
have that in their documents that
doesn't mean that they're just going to
automatically put 15% right away so I
think it's slightly being overwhelmed
but one of the biggest use cases of ETFs
is by other fund managers and
institutions so I mentioned advisers
like they're the biggest target market
for these ETFs right though that they
take up two-thirds maybe 70% or more of
the assets in the ETF world in the US
that's the target market here for most
people but also institutions make up a
huge chunk of this they were these
things were built for Institution to be
trading vehicles and right now for the
most part many institutions can't hold
this thing like they're literally
restricted from doing it because of the
way that they were structured and built
and this rapper will allow them to get
exposure to this asset class within the
bounds of of how they were created um so
yeah we we'll see all right my friend
thank you so much for doing this uh
congratulations to both of you guys in
terms of all the great work you've done
uh it's been a pleasure watching it and
we'll definitely talk again soon thanks
mob good chat